Malik the train continues five and a
half out of six this must be the
tournament of your life uh your initial
reaction to this incredible result after
six yeah I'm actually very much
surprised I don't know what's going on
I'm it is treatment of my life I mean
I'm playing well I mean I don't know I'm
trying I'm working every day myself and
it looks like so funny because works
perfectly I again I knewed about this
opening I predicted I kind of got
prepared for this and
um
I don't know
um I was in my I thought he's going to
play French but then he played this e45
then I figured I didn't want to make a
deal with this building if not another
six so because the only good game he
played in this tournament in my opinion
there was a game against Benjamin
I mean he was winning yeah he was
winning yeah he was clearly like if he
would play like nothing D3 He was like
pretty much crushing there yes so I
figure he's going to repeat this I also
found his old games back to 70s 80s when
he played uh e496 not F3 I mean F5
F5 right yeah efd5 then I had some
prepare something there as well uh but
then I knew he's gonna play E5 he's
going to get back to this like um
because he was expected for me to play
The Royal peso or Italian I thought okay
so this is actually very tricky line
it's a Wonderland switch in my opinion
the video underrated kind of uh this
Knight C3 underestimated for uh four
nights and yeah this is consideration I
Believe by the way in my opinion I'm
wrong but I fixed cities and accuracy
City okay how come oh because I think
Bishop G4 much better move Bishop to G4
first okay
very interesting yeah this is about yeah
then Bishop page five and then we have
DC Queen D4 checking h163 all this
position so um
I don't play that yeah many times to get
my media Arrow so this is like a very
well known position so this is H3 yeah
actually H6 is also I'm not sure because
people usually play like C6 right away
first yeah allows Bishop G5 then H6 and
things of that nature well why do you
feel like this is on the race well I
wanted to get position something like
this I wanted to get slightly a slightly
tiny Edge and put a long game and keep
you should uh thank your coach right yes
yeah coach yeah thank you I also by the
way another coach my good friend uh
buddy Thompson from Phoenix Arizona he
was like he's a student like he's my
good friend he's also like telling me
like what should I do how should I
behave you know all this stuff like fun
as you asked me yesterday like how
should I should I be aggressive should I
right right right right yeah I mean you
made some interesting hand motions you
know I knew how to behave how to play
the game but I just wanted to confirm
yes yes very good very good all right so
yeah but I mean I got what I wanted and
I think uh after all the straights uh
yeah I thought I'm supposed to be better
yeah Bishop he says I don't know I don't
like mobishop E6 right yeah he was
trying too much to exchange the pieces
right exactly I think Bishop must build
this diagonal to protect the F5 Square
that's right on E6 in general so yeah
Queen D4 that before I think it's a
brand of 94 okay I thought it's blunder
because no position blunder because
um he's supposed to stay like uh stay
chill you know like between the sixth
Queen C7 it's about equal but not easy
also because you have the night I had
some prospects for sure yeah uh but
don't keep on that E4 it's actually uh
much more after look you want I thought
I'm actually uh better you are yes yeah
but then I start to like a kind of um I
did like my way my play yeah I mean kind
of queen Depot was a bad move okay I
missed um I thought I mean I have some
kind of you know whatever like uh Vision
to jump on D7 uh with the rook and blah
blah blah but it was all right that's
supposed to be saying Consolidated like
control diagonal make sure that
nothing's going on maybe rookie three
not easy right I mean the material is
very limited I know
but then they realized after Queen G4 H5
21 here I realized okay my plan's
supposed to be get back to control this
diagonal and try to see like what's
going on in the game yeah so USS descent
yeah I think I think he can't trade I
mean I think it's whenever he tried the
Rooks I'm not sure about like uh I think
by the way mistake was when he uh played
uh King f8
yeah on king3 he's supposed to be doing
Atomic check it's important to check
here
maybe kick you on day two yes and
somehow hold this position I'm not sure
if it's holdable or not but he can allow
me to to play a king before and uh yeah
it's not a messy yeah because when he
plays King afraid now King the four is
challenging because if you don't play
Rook D7 then I'm going to go King C5
game over yes yeah but but the end game
I think supposed to be lost it is Ross
right that was right right yeah yeah I
don't think you ever uh
is it right plant f38 G4 you have a
couple of plants here I think this is
one of them I believe H4 was also worse
yeah B5 then get the king to uh E5 and
then F4 F5 I was I was looking for that
yeah but I thought F3 is more accurate I
don't mean I'm wrong I thought F3 to
create like a second passer yeah and
then to nail the prone structure yeah
yeah I don't think you ever let him off
the hook yeah yeah no no opponent is
supposed to be lost yeah but this is the
most important moment of the game I have
to tell you because we have a huge
argument here and I told them
Queen A1 is the easy win yeah they were
saying King C7 yeah
it's like a classic come on classic
thank you thank you all right any
questions guys because I have no
questions
we were trying to vote Christian off the
show and we were saying if you had
played the move King she's seven we
would have carried you around the
streets of St Louis
wanted to play King C5 right right but I
thought this kind of you know
I call it Destiny yes
one important question you were saying
at the beginning of the show that he
doesn't have ambition right you are
saying that you are just here to play
chess but now you have two points lead
maxing loogie lost today uh so how is
your mindset changing because he has
just three rounds to go giant Advantage
leading the tournament uh how do you
feel uh no pressure tomorrow's new day
new game just continue playing uh as
nothing's going on because there is a
every player here it's like you know
selected one very strong one so you
can't relax on this field so right
tomorrow I'm playing Gregory I mean
among the most experienced player so and
we always had like a tough games against
each other
so tomorrow is going to be I guess a
task for me if I deserve to uh to you
know be in the first place or something
like that we'll see right yeah but
there's no pressure I'm getting more
relaxed meditating I mean with two point
lead who wouldn't be here very relaxed
our congratulations
thank you enjoy your support is valuable
come on
[Laughter]
no breath what kind of it's easier right
it's true it it's true a couple of 20
minutes before that
we're having too much fun here but uh
yeah